How might we live in harmony with nature?
And if you go one step further,
and I think I'll put this into context of all the different things I've been
doing,
whether it is for example the advisory or making a physical environment,
zero waste,
you know,
like not having an impact on,
on the environment or looking at the sort of the data that we can collect from
smart cities and sensors and things like that to understand how best we can make
those decisions for future designs,
buildings,
et Cetera.
Um,
one thing that I'm super interested in at the moment is the use of new
technologies like fourth industrial revolution type technologies and
understanding how people like us are actually using dialogue to understand how
best we can understand that technology in the context of the lives that we want
to live with the philosophy that we have.
So it's as if that philosophy was the basis and the foundation and then you're
going to build everything on top of it.
Another thing that I'm looking at,
and I'm much more practical level,
is really looking at how businesses procure that products and their services.
And going into the site supply chains and understanding at that supply chain,
where do you get your products from?
Where the resources coming from and is there an alternative that we can have say
shared economy or whether it is that when you're going to be designing your
startup,
the material that you're using for your products is actually having a beneficial
environmental impact.
It is also about understanding where our conduct construction industry,
which is where 40% of our climate,
um,
you know,
carbon related emissions are coming from can actually be reduced to a lot of the
physical environment that we either live in work in.
It's still going to be here 50 years time,
right?
I mean,
can you imagine Aleppo a thousand year old city is still alive today.
It's been bashed about,
you know,
there've been multiple wars and this is just another one to add to its history,
but it's a thousand year old city like Damascus's.
Right?
And so it's a really interesting relationship that we have with the,
the,
the consequences that were almost like Italo Calvino the urbanist would say that
humans have left a scar on the city.
Right?
Your relationship with the city has,
has remained.
It's like whatever you did in that city creates the legacy of that city.
And so that's the sort of some of the thoughts that I'm sharing with you through
the presentation.
But also the things that I get up to research is really interesting for me
because it's,
uh,
it's an opportunity to put a lot of the,
the theoretical models together with the practical,
right?
There's no point in running a business and as a,
you know,
the theory behind it,
a lot of people go to university to learn the theory but then don't know how to
put it into practice.
And that is the big challenge.
How do you put what you've learned,
like economics into practice when you actually go and leave university.
And then finally when it comes to the relationship that we have with
information,
it's like you can,
I can talk to you until you're blue in the face about certain issues,
but I haven't really,
your form of communication,
if you want to learn something,
there are many ways that you learn.
But the way that you learn it is in the context that you know,
right?
If I give you an immersive experience that's going to teach a way more than
something that you would have to theorize before you went into the practice of.
So a big thing for me is how do you engage people in the longer mission with
giving them these sort of immersive experiences.
So the big question is considering we now live in ecosystems and systems and
cities and an economic systems that are so interconnected,
how do we develop or how might we develop an ecosystem that replenishes planet
earth?
So what do I mean by replenishing,
right?
Replenishing is really being carbon negative.
Like the Prime Minister of Bhutan took sponsoring top gay and his incredible Ted
Talk.
He talks about this idea that he's having a positive,
his country is having a positive impact on the environment.
That means that you're not zeroing out.
It's not like a zero carbon.
I've spent the carbon,
I've now sequestered it.
It's going beyond that so that you've got some sort of regenerative capacity
that you're providing planet.
Uh,
it means that you're giving something back in the form.
The earth can actually compose,
like composted and that it has a positive environment,
environmental impact.
So really it's like sustaining the status quo is the way in which a lot of us
for about a good 20 years of being exploring markets and products,
it's like we're going to match that.
We're going to sustain the status quo.
But how can we go beyond that?
It's like,
you know,
if,
if we don't,
from now on,
we make a pledge.
Everything that we buy is 100% compostable.
We don't at everything is recyclable.
Nothing goes to landfill sites.
Right?
But what's then going to happen about the Great Pacific gyre?
Who's going to clean that up.
If every country and every citizen in the world,
everyone in the world decides that we're not going to create any more waste,
but who's going to take responsibility for our Global Commons are urban commons,
our communal impact.
That is a legacy that we've inherited and I think this is what I'm trying to get
to.
How can you,
how can we get to a point where we create systems naturally,
whether it's to tech tech platforms or physical platforms that can actually give
more than we're taking.
So I started to explore,
as I mentioned in 2015 around about then what replenish actually meant.
And since then I've been on this huge exploration and I realized to bring back
that economics,
right?
Looking at GDP,
which is,
you know,
you can spend money and it will look brilliant on the accounts of a,
of a country like GDP looks brilliant.
Oh,
it's rising,
we're spending a lot of money.
But then these expenditures,
where are they going?
What's the impact of them?
I could be spending money on cigarettes that have a negative impact on my
health,
which then somebody else is going to be paying for,
whether it's through national health service or me,
right?
Is the fact that I've spent money on something and there's no judgment here,
you know,
but it's the fact that I've spent money on something then going to relate to a
longer term impact on expenditure,
whether is a lung replacement for like a,
there is actually going to have a negative impact on the health of a person,
but it looks great on GDP because I've spent so much money on cigarettes or
whatever else.
So there's no actual,
um,
ethical or moral or environmental consciousness about that expenditure.
So how do we adjust GDP to also include in the expenditure that it has a
positive impact or a negative impact or neutral impact.
And so I wanted to explore that through something called the world's replenish
index.
Imagine if GDP globally was adjusted by every product and service to the
environmental impact that it had.
What instead of GDP would you have like a replenish count?
Just like you know,
I'm going to pick up your bottle assuming that it has like a calorie counter at
the back of it,
which it does and then all of a sudden I'm looking at this plastic bottle and I
can have like replenished count,
right?
This product is level five,
let's say it's not there yet,
but it's at level five or replenish meaning that your diet for replenish,
like your diet,
it would be for something that you consume was related to the association you
have with replenishing planet earth and that's where I want to get to.
There's a lot of information that I need before I get there.
There's a lot of research that I need to do before I get there,
but that's my mission to try and find a way that we can develop some kind of
metric that we could measure how people were positively impacting planet,
planet earth,
and I do this three universities at the moment I've worked,
I've been working with a number of Indian universities.
I feel as if if there's one place where I can go to that could,
I could have a big impact.
I feel that it's India and the reason for that is 450 million people moving from
villages,
migrating to cities only to find,
there's no way that they can go in there,
go and live in slums and mostly work in a landfill site.
And I want to stop them from going there.
So how do I give them the resources that they need in a way that at the
beginning they're living there replenish lifestyle,
which is positive impact on planet earth from,
from Gecko,
but how do I connect them up in their rural sort of super remote areas and give
them the resources that they need to be able to live a lifestyle that is
appropriate for the environment.
A while ago you might've heard of the one planet living lifestyle,
right?
And that's very similar to the way that I'm trying to explore this.
I took some students around the world through a university that I found in 2015
and I started to explore India's 100 smart cities is this huge project that the
Indian government has undertaken.
But with the 100 smart cities,
it doesn't mean that you got smart citizens.
So when the university asked me,
would you explore what a smart city is?
I said,
no,
I don't want to.
I don't believe that you can design a smart city with without designing smart
citizens.
It's like the building is smart,
but we're not.
It's like the city is smart,
So the emphasis is on the technology,
not us.
It's not the fact that my consciousness has improved and now I'm,
you know,
really aware of what my building is doing.
I have no intuitive capacity with the building.
I have no relationship with the building.
I am a node inside the building or the city.
I have nothing to do with the city.
The city corrects itself.
The city manages itself.
The city is designed so that it makes its decisions without me.
But I'm the one who's a member of the city and society and community and this
company,
let's say,
so what do I have to give as an individual citizen and how is my data being used
to then make those decisions and do I have ownership of that?
I mean these are big questions I think we can't really answer in one session,
but one of the questions I really wanted to ask was what is smart citizenship?
If you had an opportunity to design a city,
how would you design it?
If you had an opportunity to live in a particular place,
where would you live?
Why?
Why would you live there?
If you had an opportunity to go further into where your data was going to be
used,
picked up,
and then analyze and sold,
shouldn't you get a dividend on that?
And these are sort of broader questions that I've been asking through these
courses,
but I really wanted to get students to take them out of the university
experience and put them into physical spaces where the physical space was
teaching them the lesson that I wanted to teach them.
Right?
Instead of giving them a,
uh,
you know,
a lecturer of something.
So one of the things that I ended up doing was taking my students to be Tan.
Or at first they were like,
ma'am,
you're going to take us to Bhutan.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'd like to take you to Bhutan.
They were like,
but it's next to our country.
Why do we have to go there?
Why don't you take us to London?
And I said,
let me take you there.
And then we'll explore what Tan really is.
And they were complaining too.
We got to Bhutan and in the end,
even though I took them to Masdar city so they can explore Masdar city,
I took them to Dubai,
I brought them here in the end,
in that one trip I asked them what was your best experience?
And they said,
Tom was.
And I said,
why you didn't want to go there?
And now all of a sudden that's like one of your favorite places.
How can they said,
you know,
when we first arrived there,
the one thing that we explored was the fact that they had such beautiful,
clean water.
Some of these students had never seen such clean,
natural water in rivers because a lot of that included,
uh,
many of them had never seen a place that sequestered more carbon than they made
because they live next door to it.
But it's just,
it's,
it's like unbelievable.
They run out as soon as I arrived and we all arrived into Baton Rouge Paro
airport,
we're in a bus,
we're going along to like tempo.
The bus stops for some reason,
I'm like snoozing off.
All the kids run off and I'm like,
what's happened?
And I come outside and they're taking selfies with the clear water and I'm
thinking,
why are you taking a selfie with the river?
And that's the point.
It was a fact that they had lived such clean air that when I go back to
[inaudible],
which was one of the top two polluted cities in India,
they realize that other things were possible,
right?
The,
I took them equally to Japan and in Japan they realize that what 32 different
types of recycling and you've got like clear streets.
I mean who cleans them up?
Well it's the community.
Does the community clears up the streets man.
And I'm like,
yeah,
it's called rent high secondhand.
Every month everyone comes up with a broomstick and they will clean it up and
you go to like a Japanese school,
the kids come out once,
you know,
a half an hour,
one hour during the day and then we'll come and clean up the whole school are
the pay to do that?
He said no,
you know that they don't have maids and so on to clean it up.
But no,
that was a joke for Dubai.
Um,
sorry.
So then I really wanted,
I sort of explored the research angle of it,
but another thing I really wanted to do was to take some of these students on a
longer journey.
So I took about six different research projects or related to recycling because
I strongly sense that our relationship,
not just with the physical environment affecting our brain and changing our
chemistry,
but also if we got them to study the,
the way that,
I don't know if you'd been to India,
if you have your,
you'll understand and agree with me,
is that you walk down the street and you're just got piles of rubbish everywhere
and the informal and no one cleans them up and if they do get cleaned up,
they're put in a informal landfill site and you look at that and you think,
well you know what kind of normal is this?
What kind of normal is this?
This is the norm.
Meaning every time I walk out that's a blind spot that doesn't exist.
What you're talking about,
I can't see anymore because that's become my normal.
And it's interesting because if you were to clean it up for about 30 days,
let's say you'd make an imprint of a clean spot and now if there was any
rubbish,
like someone's put some rubbish there.
And it's really interesting how habits are formed through the visual
relationship that we have with cities.
So I wanted to explore that with some of my students and I did that and informal
sector of ways and how,
where it goes,
there was a whole black market of waste,
which we picked up on and documented.
But then what I wanted to do was give them an opportunity and also a lot of the
people that lived in and about an opportunity to explore what it meant to be
inspired by a fellow Indian,
no,
not a Florida.
No,
not someone that you could say,
well they went to Harvard University,
but somebody that could have been a neighbor down the street.
And it was like,
wow,
how do I find people that could inspire them and that they could explore what it
meant to be an Indian living in today's India.
But those who are actually challenging the same things that they were living
through,
but ignoring.
And that was a blind spot.
So I picked some incredible people.
I don't know if you remember,
there was a documentary recently where the ad will spoons,
you know,
like national geographic did like the ad spoons and you know,
I many be like single use plastics that we use.
But this guy came along said,
forget throwing in a more way,
let's make them edible.
And so we created these lento based,
um,
you know,
spoons and things so that people could actually eat with.
And so I,
you know,
we invited him over to be one of the speakers and I kind of wanted a ted style,
inspirational 20 minutes that you can explore what have I done with some of the
biggest challenges of India.
And that was the first talk series that we created in January,
followed by,
uh,
make a fast.
So,
you know,
we really want you to go into the grassroots innovation and bring that out.
So really,
um,
one of my inspirations from childhood has been Sir David Attenborough.
I don't know if you remember,
if you make from England,
you might remember his voice and it was the,
you know,
he's documenting the way that people live,
planet earth.
You know it,
he'll talk about like the story and the narrative behind the way that this
animal is doing this and look at the way that he is and the reason why he's
doing it.
And,
and it was this beautiful narrative,
planet earth.
But I really,
I,
I completely get what he's saying here and that is that no one will protect what
they don't care about and no one will care about what they have never
experienced.
So how do we create this physical experiences?
Because I think an education and an expert says not just in the head,
right?
If it were,
then I'll just give you,
you know,
some kind of augmented reality or virtual reality and you live there and I'm
sure you'll get some physical repercussions of that relationship too.
So one of the things that we ended up doing in Goa this year was to question,
where can your height waist?
Is it that on earth?
You can put it,
I put it on your desk and the lady says,
no,
kind of put it in your room.
I mean,
you're the one who bought it.
You keep it.
Not my responsibility.
Why are you getting it?
Giving it to me?
No,
I'm not going to keep it in my room.
Why not?
It's yours.
So if you were to live with your waste for one week in your room,
in your bedroom,
like turn around,
where would you go?
But how long could you live with your own waste?
Right.
And it's interesting because if I were to put all of my ways and a mountain,
right,
I don't know how big that mountain would be and I,
I've started to realize,
oh my God,
where is that going?
So where are we hiding our waste?
And so that is a question.
We then put a whole installation together and the Indian government was really
impressed with it.
They asked us,
can we make it a permanent installation?
So they gave us a,
a shipping container and then we painted it all black.
We put these incredible UV sort of,
uh,
using black lights,
sort of paints.
And uh,
and then we took them on a mini journey around this installation.
And the point of it was,
what is a seahorse doing,
holding a straw?
It's was like,
why are the plastics in the ocean?
Who does he belong to?
And then as you go through,
there's like a very kitty's,
you know,
kitty friendly and adult friendly sort of dialogue that we create with people as
they're going through the installation.
Got to a point at the back where they had all of these beautiful,
um,
you know,
a jellyfish and they're just jellyfish,
right?
And you're looking at the bad,
wow.
The kids are like,
they're jellyfish and like,
are you sure the jellyfish,
the jellyfish?
And then I'm like,
wrong.
And like you,
this turtle has no idea that that is not a jellyfish.
It's a plastic bag.
And so it was really this opportunity that I had to question the plastics,
but through the lifestyles that we're living,
and I,
I think just on the right hand side of this picture,
you'll get to see like this,
the shrine that I put together for all of the different kinds of plastics that
anyone could have had.
So then turned to them and said,
oh,
is this your plastic bag?
I don't know.
Could it be,
could it be mine?
You know,
is that your store?
And then to sort of explore this dialogue of plastics and plastic diet,
it's like a plastic footprint.
And then the other thing that I really wanted to explore through this
installation was microplastics.
We talk about,
you know,
plastics being in the ecosystem,
but are we consuming that plastic too?
And there is research in so many different countries now,
India as well.
That's shocking and scares me.
So what he said was that scientists cannot find a single sample of water around
the world that doesn't have plastic inside it.
Now what's really interesting and most of our water bodies are completely
connected in most of our water bodies.
A lot of that plastic comes together and that's where we've got these big,
like Ellen Macarthur has traveled around the world and found out that there's
huge garbage patches,
which are the size of,
you know,
countries like there's one the size of France floating about and there's no sun
that goes through to photosynthesize.
Um,
you know,
the,
the algae.
But what's really fascinating for me is that microplastic that breakdown our
founder night,
the underwater,
but they're also found in the animals now also found in us.
What's that stage where the plastic that we're putting out in the world comes
back and hits us into our stomachs.
I wonder if there is a way that now we can actually start analyzing how many
plastics exist in us.
There's a bit of a grim story I suppose and the Times of India picked up on it
and said that,
you know,
there's some things that we should be able to sort of communicate through an
installation.
The Hindustan waste plant is put that installation on their ground.
So if any of you are ever going to go or you are welcome to go and visit it,
but the point of the insulation wasn't,
Oh my God,
plastics are taking over the world.
It was,
what are the three things that you can do now that you walk out of here that can
have a huge impact for planet earth.
One of them say no to plastic bags like single use plastic bags with straws.
Right.
Get it.
Get your own store and just like when you're about to audio food,
and I've got preferences,
I don't like onions,
let's say.
Then you,
you tell people don't hear you say a order that pizza without onions please.
In the same way ordered my drink without a plastic straw.
And now that I've started doing that,
and I remember there was a cafe down the street from the installation,
people would look at me and say,
you don't want a straw.
I said,
do you know what?
Do me a favor.
Don't give anyone this week a straw,
but keep them there.
Keep the stores there,
but don't give it to them.
If they ask for it,
they know where to find it.
So that's like one step that you could take that reduces the amount of plastic.
But also instead of having multiple plastic bottles for water,
how about if you had one refillable water right?
And one of those big containers that you can actually just refill instead of
having plastic bottles and every single day,
I don't know how much,
how many of these plastic bottles we seem to be consuming.
So at the point of it wasn't how awful are we guilt tripping them,
but actually getting them to a point of saying,
well what can I do now that I can cancel it tangibly take that away.
So now moving into this whole idea of dialogue,
a lot of the communication that we've been given is a,
I find traumatizing makes me feel awful.
Or it just want to like climb underneath the blanket and cry.
But what do we do to have this conversation?
How do we get there?
This is like,
imagine if every,
every single person on planet earth could have a replenish lifestyle could
actually benefit planet earth in some way.
So it's a dual thing.
Number one is how do we have that dialogue?
I mean,
I don't know if any of you have been recipients of trolling online,
but I have and it feels horrible.
You know,
it's like,
why are you doing this?
And you know,
never had me and you got an opinion on who I am as a person.
But that kind of dialogue and the relationship that we have with one another I
think is really important.
It's a margin.
If like we're sitting at dinner and three of you,
you've got your phones out and your mom sitting there and saying,
well put your phones away.
Most of the conversation we should have had at the beginning to then get to a
point where at dinner agreed negotiations over here,
we're compromising on this table.
We're not going to have phones.
Fine,
cool.
Do it before the after,
but not at the dinner table.
Now that you've had this conversation,
that is like the foundation,
the process that you're going to use for that dialogue.
That is important for a lot of the technology that is coming into our lives.
So in the same way,
a lot of like 4.0 um,
so many different kinds of technologies are actually on market.
But is there a point where we need to learn how to best dialogue with each other
to form some social parameters,
some kind of,
you know,
conversations,
nonviolent communication that can actually get us on par with where we need to
go next and how do we have that conversation.
So,
um,
I tried to say the beginning of this year,
I came together with Dx labs based in San Francisco.
They work with singularity as well.
And one of the things that I really wanted to do was write an article,
a story about what would happen if you lived with a neuro link,
if you,
let's say where I'm completely online with brain.
I mean a lot of that technology has,
has,
has come into some sort of research laboratories and,
and I,
I kind of imagined what it would feel like to have a brain machine interface,
but instead of getting to the point where having opinions for some reasons,
stories,
like really cool stories like psych,
find stories and videos and movies can allow us to ask those questions in a safe
space.
So I started to,
to write and on a medium I wrote this post replenish the convergence of AI and
ecology.
And there's two parts and I'd love to know what you thought about it.
But what was for me really intriguing is that there comes a point where
technology and nature merge the margin.
You know,
you might,
you might know meow meow who's got like a biometric scanner in his arm.
And then he sort of uploads the data.
So we're coming to that point of quantified self.
I've got a fitbit fitbit on me.
You know,
we're getting to that point where we're merging with tech and at that point,
at what point at,
yeah,
where do we become the technology that we're also introducing into our lives?
And it's a really interesting question for me because imagine if the whole of
our brain was uploaded onto the internet and that brain could then be analyzed
and your thoughts analyze and whatever kind of interesting behaviors we had
could in some way even be controlled or manipulated.
But if we had an opportunity to actually enhance that and put that forward,
we can have a dialogue about it.
Where would we,
where would that dialogue go?
But also about the sort of the automation,
I think of life,
the automation of a lot of the challenges that we've got.
Where do we get to a point where that automation becomes with or without the
direction that we're giving it?
Here's,
uh,
some of the research that we did on the whole brain,
but also like where would we put that technology and having conversations about
it.
And it's been really interesting to explore this technology through the lens of
an individual who would say,
I would never have something like that done.
But to explore it through a story is much easier.
And so to have that conversation,
even though it's not real,
it's almost easier for people to sort of interact with.
So we talked about,
you know,
uh,
industry 4.0 and entering the market,
but are also when it comes to the sustainable development goals that the United
Nations had launched was how much is this industry worth?
Should we really bother about it?
And the wife was actually put,
uh,
some two point 5 trillion on it.
I think the next step is really to understand where we can go with that.
If you had two point $5 trillion of a budget towards this,
where would we direct our research?
What kind of businesses would we create?
What kind of cities would we design?
So some of the work that I've been doing here has been in,
I mentioned like the,
the golf benchmark on energy.
What that then led to was uh,
an article I think in the Gulf with the national that was too cold for comfort,
actual physical buildings being way too cold and people getting ill from them.
And that was where the National Bank of Abu Dhabi,
some of the work that I've done and trying to explore whether it should be a top
down or a bottom up approach,
where are the smart cities taking us and where do we have an opportunity to be
part of that.
There was a project that I did with the premier of South Australia,
a jai row and it was really about understanding what does carbon negative mean
or carbon neutral made and where can we push the boundaries of that.
So it's,
it's interesting because
whoever we are are based on the experiences that we've had.
But when we start to combine our knowledge and experiences,
we almost actualize a community of knowledge,
like a collaboration.
But it's like going beyond that.
That's really interesting to understand.
Like,
how do we get to a point where we can really explore all of our learnings
together through this?
And,
and with that,
our fears,
and this really goes back to a very interesting project in the UK,
which a friend of mine has got,
his name is Simon Gosling.
Um,
and he's exploring what smart means.
So he brings people into this future home and explores the dialogues that is
having with them.
So if you're ever in London,
I'd love to introduce you to him.
And this is a very small project that I've got with about 300 villages
surrounding Suta,
which is one of the fastest growing cities in India.
But as you can see,
one of the big projects of India is,
uh,
others gum,
which is about that kind of ideal village and exploring what that means,
even though,
you know,
you walk down the street and you've got these piles and piles of rubbish.
So how do we take this whole replenish philosophy and plug it into the rural
sector and actually help people to transition to that kind of a lifestyle.
Um,
another thing that I did recently was in Brazil where we had,
we celebrated a whole week of zero waste and one of the most exciting things
that I saw was an actual supermarket that is 96% and it's a massive supermarket
Asif market that is 96% zero waste.
And you know,
we,
we developed and designed some ideas for Lisbon being a zero waste city.
But I think we're at that almost at that point where a lot of cities and a lot
of companies are taking on much more practical levels of appreciating and
translating this kind of philosophy.
So you can find out more about me on our newsletter.
I normally kind of post any new bits or a new piece of information that I
collect.
Um,
the next steps for me really are consolidating about 10 years worth of travel
and understanding what,
what is next.
Like if we were to introduce this whole economic paradigm,
like the world replenish index and you had at the back of your bottles and
everything that you consumed or replenish indicator,
would you live a replenish diet?
Like,
and,
and how much of that would be your lifestyle?
You know,
how,
let's say I'm Vegan,
right?
But I'm Vegan in my diet,
not my lifestyle.
How would I translate the Vegan to the lifestyle as well?
How do I translate this lifestyle into something that is appropriate for planet
earth?
Some exploring these things.
I was really grateful to have shared some of my work with you.
Uh,
but also some of the challenges and the questions that are leading me in the
vision that I've got for it.
I really hope that in maybe 10 to 20 years time,
we can look back and say that the planet that we live on is an ecosystem that
we're part of,
but it's an ecosystem that were together with that we can work together on
creating a replenish earth or replenishing lifestyle from.
I think there's this,
these ideas almost of like,
you know,
moving away from the challenges of living in a life,
a lifestyle like this,
but,
and maybe it's going backwards,
you know,
going to live in a village in India is not necessarily the challenge,
but exploring those things in the cities.
And the buildings and the,
the companies that we live and work in.
So thank you very much for your time.
[inaudible]
the floor is yours.
Any questions please?
Yes.
Hi.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
Very inspiring story and project to working on.
Thank you.
My question is it all of this I've learned,
this is a fascinating challenge because from one side,
our actions as an individual was individually impact,
negatively land,
earth,
but we don't treat the benefits unless we act collectively either at the local
level or at the country level or even at an earth,
which makes our action.
The in fact,
the mold from the option that we do as individual and breaking the special with
this vicious cycle of us doing good actions and seeing the benefit is very
critical now that are a lot of government action from a regulation point of
view,
which I did around effective or not subject to what it takes and the economy.
Oh,
great.
Comics and technology clearly has some,
um,
uh,
efficiency promise for companies.
But I know what you mentioned about raping,
get to an individual lesson and having the index on every water or an FD
broader.
So my question for you is that when we see a gallery or an organic label
[inaudible] for individually path of,
when we see a labor,
we cannot relate the two hour individually when being,
unless everyone has sign up for it.
How do you think are the most interesting ideas and the most effective one in
relating more this index or seminar labors to individually when the intangible
that's such a,
it's such an interesting way of seeing it and I'm really grateful that you
brought this to our attention because I think that individual,
almost like a,
you know,
per capita income,
who cares about per capita income apart from the fact that I'm part of this
economy,
right?
Per capita income.
It's got nothing to do with me personally.
It's what the government is actually assigning to the wellbeing financially of
this member who lives in this country.
So this is a very interesting concept because now it identifies who I am as an
individual,
right?
The fact that I'm a Vegan,
it's got nothing to do with else.
And this,
if we're going to go,
I'd tell everybody they should stop eating meat because it hasn't a negative
impact on the environment.
But I could have a lifestyle that is completely wrong.
And that's really interesting because now with data,
just like you would do with your smart phone data and what you're consuming on
an individual level,
imagine if that data backed up who you were as a person.
China's introducing already this social indexing,
right?
Imagine if each person had some kind of even account that could bring them
credit for doing certain things.
And it may be that turned into money like a monetary taxation,
right?
That you didn't have to pay because,
hey,
I,
you don't need to collect my rubbish.
I don't have any.
So now like it turns this whole idea of civic,
right?
This whole community communal.
If,
if I,
let's say in China for example,
that,
um,
the hospital that is all about preventative health,
right?
It's not about how many chemicals and you know medicines can I have now that
I've got ill,
but it's how do I stop you from getting ill in the first place?
I think that's the kind of approach that we need to take for planet earth.
How do we stop her getting ill in the first place and how in on an individual
scale can we incentivize individuals that we are part of that global ecosystem.
This is the biggest challenge because if you can crack that,
you cracked it all cause on that individual level you need to know how much
you've done.
I'm selfish,
you know,
if I've,
if I spent more money on creating maybe a leed platinum building or whatever
rating system per five,
I want to get some benefit from that.
And that might be an ego thing,
right?
But it depends on the consciousness of the individual.
Perhaps.
I don't need you to tell me that I've done well.
So it depends on the person and the community at the time of how that
incentivization scheme could work.
But I could totally see that some kind of economic benefits,
tariffs,
quotas that you could meet.
The could actually would use,
not just the global sort of parameters,
but a local parameter.
Imagine in the UK we've got like the Bristol pound,
you know we've got currency in a certain locale.
Now that I've got the purchase path,
the Bristol pound and the British pound or equal,
they are equally used in Bristol.
But the fact that I've now got to local currency means that my current who
remains within Bristol because it can't be used in London.
So it's like a localization of a global issue.
I don't know if that really answered your question.
I wasn't meaning to answer the question,
but add a few more thoughts to it because I don't think anyone's got the answer.
Yes,
I am not at the moment.
I'm trying.
So for example,
I don't eat meat.
I don't eat fish.
That's one thing that I'm trying to do.
The second thing is I don't buy anything anymore.
I borrow things instead.
So instead of buying more things,
like if you go into my home,
I've got all these box,
I don't know what to do with them.
And so what I'm doing is like giving those books away,
trying to understand like,
okay,
if I want to acquire knowledge,
how best do I do that?
So I'm picking different aspects of my lifestyle and exploring what I can do.
So for example,
with replenishing,
I'm finding ways that I can sequester.
Where can I perhaps not have a straw?
So through my behavior,
I'm trying to figure out how I can live a much more negative carbon negative
lifestyle.
But also what are the metrics?
Like if you look at some of the carbon sequestration metrics,
it's like,
Oh,
if we put,
if we plant another five trees and we're going to get the no,
we're not because our twin five praise that you've taken down,
or a full fledglings,
the completely grown and the sequestering capacity is not the same as like a
sapling.
And these are some of the kinds of questions that I'm asking not only myself,
but exploring through new products are on the market.
And exploring,
Hey,
these are the alternatives.
So through my own learnings,
I'm posting a lot of that through our Facebook group so that when I'm learning
something I'm like,
wow,
that's really cool.
I don't expect to be carbon neutral or negative today.
I expect to be there transitioning to it with a mindful step by step process.
It's like you know from now from one step to the other,
you're probably not going to become a nonsmoker,
but you're probably going to take measures to sort of reduce the amount of
impact of certain chemicals that you might have or you might go,
you know,
towards a natural tobacco.
Let's say that there are different measures that you can take for it.
Where's she from?
And I think you or your cause is probably one of the noblest answers to the why.
I'll see most scenic areas.
Thanks for sharing.
Thank you.
Alan Musk and his work.
He knows two things and I think they're completing.
One is trying to make life on the blend better with solar power and solar
powered cars and on the other end trying to start a colony in Mars,
sort of a safety net for encased land.
They didn't work.
What do you think of that safety net?
I find it really interesting.
So he was in Adelaide at the same time that I was there,
but it was promoting this whole,
you know,
cause we had a huge blackout in South Australia because of that.
Through a little Twitter sort of understanding.
There was this huge pot at that came about and being,
and I think that these,
I'm going to call them hairy ambitious goals,
right?
Going carbon negative or neutral is a hairy,
ambitious goal and we've got it all pig.
Like you know,
plug in different bits of knowledge and information to understand what the whole
elephant looks like.
It's like I'm blind but I can feel like the eyelashes of the,
of the elephant.
So it's brick coming together and knowing that is what the elephant is.
That's one on his mission to Mars.
I think,
you know,
I can take it like are you trying to run away?
You know,
like the,
you know that movie,
uh,
what's the name of that movie?
Would that robot that lives on planet earth and he's like packaging up like the
waist and put them,
imagine if like Wally,
we 50 years time we're getting to a point where,
you know,
we are living the [inaudible] lifestyle,
getting fat on some sort of hovering device and just like pinging each other on
the whatever Facebook,
you know,
a device we're going to be using.
And I think we can either take it that way or we could look at it as a hairy
goal.
Are we going to get somewhere?
If we were to redirect our attention to something that we could actually do and
if we could actually do that,
what then can we actually do here?
And I think there is maybe a,
um,
a small number of crazy people I think is one of them,
but crazy in a good way.
It's like saying that is a challenge that I didn't think we can do or can we?
And I think more than anything,
I take that as a learning that it,
my God,
if you can get to Mars,
what can't we do here?
And perhaps his whole Mars mission is like,
I'm going to put the money towards it because I can afford it.
He says,
but it's not to do that.
It's to bring our attention to the fact that if we were to spend time and money
on making a better,
we probably wouldn't want to go there or maybe we would want,
we'd want to go and explore it.
Just like you know,
going to the,
going to the moon was like,
we're going to go to the moon in 10 years time.
We want to get to the moon as the fact that we had 10 years' time.
It was a confined time period.
It was a huge task and that many people had to come together to to achieve that.
It's like Steve Jobs 10 years ago brings out this platform called the iPhone.
No one's ever heard of a smart phone before.
It's like what?
But he didn't do it alone.
He created something that came from an ecosystem of all of this military in
academic research that has gone into making the iPhone possible and I think this
is where someone like Elon Musk is who liked me.
He travels around the world and doesn't really have a home because planet earth
is home and it's like how do you create some kind of association to these kinds
of challenges that we globally need to be aware of.
I remember this conversation,
I've kind of taking a bit of a tangent,
but I hope you'll appreciate it.
I sat next to the Garden Nanda,
we were having a cup of tea and she says,
Tia,
I didn't really care what happens in China,
what sustainability,
and I said,
you don't care about what happens in China.
I want you to go home,
turn everything around.
Having look at the maiden and tell me how,
what percentage of your things come from where?
She said,
I did that 60% I said,
do you or do you not have,
even if it's just economic,
do you or do you not have a relationship with China?
Then
does your demand for these things,
whether you like it or not,
and there are no alternatives,
perhaps have something to do with what happens in China.
And I think this is what it is.
How can we make it visible but not make people feel guilty from it?
And that's the challenge.
How do we positively reinforce with alternatives and fun innovations and cool
ways of doing it?
And I think maybe he's a bit bonkers.
Who am I to judge?
Thanks
so on.
The
humans are like a selfless,
oh the selfish gene by Richard Dawkins.
Here we go.
We were willing to be addicted to things rather where I think doing good and if
it makes me feel good to throw away a plastic spoon,
I don't have to wash it there.
How are you going to,
once people have tasted the goodness right now,
how are you going to get them away from?
If they might argue that I'm not really in my life,
I'm going to see the consequences of what I'm doing?
That's a really good point.
I say one thing definitely.
Who seeded that idea in your head?
Personal experience.
It
could be personal experience,
but it could be anyone,
right?
At any stage,
somebody in society or through a subconscious messaging has gotten us,
me included,
to believe something that is the case.
There is no status quo.
Therefore everything can be questioned the way that we live.
For example,
I learned this when I was in Japan.
I remember coming from England,
22 years old,
just finished my university degree,
arrive into Japan.
They say,
this is wrong in England.
Okay?
I'm taking one example.
In England,
when you sitting next to somebody that you don't know at the bus stop,
you start talking about the weather,
so you'd normally talk about how shit it is.
You're like,
oh,
the weather's really bad,
isn't it?
And somebody tells you.
I was like,
yeah,
God.
It's been raining all day,
but could be good as well because what does really good today?
Oh,
oh,
it's lovely,
but second excuse to have a chat with somebody.
Well,
I went to Japan and I started to use the negative to open up dialogue and it
didn't work.
I was like,
Whoa,
I'm not being negative.
It's just some.
And then I realized the way that I do things isn't necessarily right in another
culture,
another place of the world,
and another conversation.
It doesn't,
just because one way is right doesn't mean another way as well too.
And I think that's a very interesting psychological waiting or anchoring that
we've all been exposed to.
If you go back to,
I think it was a 1950s and sixties,
Edward Bernays was one of the most incredible PR agents at the time.
What he did,
Marlboro Smoking Company,
uh,
went to him and said,
we don't have any women's smokers.
What do we do about it?
He went and did some research.
He found out that women felt a certain way about smoking and putting this stick
into the mouth was something that they didn't want to do.
So then he explored how the relationship and the,
and the sort of branding behind it,
right,
but explored what did it mean for them,
explored the meaning and how we could shift that meaning and made an incredible
difference.
He hired 10 beautiful women the beginning of a march for female freedom,
gave them all cigarettes,
lit them up,
call the press,
took some photographs and boom.
Did that one event have a huge impact on the that females were smoking
cigarettes for.
It's really interesting for me,
but the way that we influence people and it's psychological messaging that we
give them,
whether it's commercials,
whether it's data that we analyze and and show.
I think a lot of that intention has been set by someone or something,
mostly for reasons of their own causes.
Right.
I'm going to try and sell you a Cocacola Cola can,
no matter what I can do,
even if I'm stepping on a Pepsi can
in an advert.
But I know and you know that it's got like huge amounts of sugar and a chemical
that stops my mouth exploring that there is too much sugar in my mouth.
Is that fair or not fair?
Well it's not,
uh,
it's FDA approved.
Okay,
fine.
So it's really interesting how a lot of that research now at all of our
experimentation has allowed to us maybe becoming more conscious about certain
things or not.
And I don't think anything is written.
I think we have an opportunity to explore everything.
Like a teacher that I used to have in one of my classes when I was younger,
she used to say,
well that's just the way that it is.
And I'm saying,
well,
I don't think so.
What's up inside me tells me it's not that way.
But she would often say,
well that's just the way that it is.
So it's,
it's interesting if you were to explore another way of being another language,
another narrative,
another identity.
And you had no holes barred,
who would you be?
Hmm.
Anyone,
sorry.
Sorry.
Um,
what did the time go?
I was a very interested in the index.
You wearing that when you talk to a,
I don't know,
or um,
or even anyone in ecosystem that this,
that a country in the world that a,
this is interested in doing these.
Is it something that was completely of going to happen and we're going to be
done also not wanting this to happen
all of a sudden just school.
So what's the state of this?
It's a really good question.
So Bhutan this year launched the Gnh business.
Butan introduced the Gross National Happiness index in the 1970s and wanted to
understand what if the economy wasn't about money,
but it was about wellbeing.
And so they started to explore this whole wellbeing.
And in 19,
I think it was 19 seventy's own woods is when every three years,
all of this data was collected to show what was the state of wellbeing and their
country.
And then what they did was to explore.
I happen this report and I think you may be aware that many other countries
around the world have been looking at wellbeing,
a British government being one of them.
The UAE has been talking about wellbeing as well.
Happiness ministers.
Very interesting sort of understanding appreciation of wellbeing.
Another thing that they've recently launched last year,
a couple of years ago,
they did the gross national seven conference or set the conference this year it
was the seventh and they said,
what if businesses were also aligned with this?
And I said,
okay,
well you get to be introducing this to businesses already and probably taking a
top down approach.
They took 40 different businesses and ask them whether they were approaching
their businesses with the kind of wellbeing index within the context of the
products and services and the employees that work that kind of like the
organizational structure.
And when this came out,
one of the things that I suggested to the Bhutanese primaries but also their
team at the center of Brittany studies was you're doing the wellbeing.
Why don't you also do the environmental side of it too?
So if you were to like be Kobes analyze the whole business and the impact that
it had on the environment as well as the wellbeing,
what kind of a metric would you have?
You'd be the first in the world to do it.
So we're exploring that together.
It's funny actually,
you know,
um,
at the beginning of the year when I was writing the convergence of AI and
ecology piece,
I watch all of the Black Mirror series.
I don't know if you've come across this so much fun.
I loved it.
Um,
and one of the things that I came across was if I could write a piece for the
future,
like 40 years,
maybe even 30 or 10 years of how this could be,
I want to get crazy.
And I wrote that it then became the preliminary piece for the,
for the medium article.
But one of the things that I wrote was in two years time,
the,
and I wrote it as opposed to looking back.
So,
uh,
two years ago this suggestion was made and then this was implant,
you know,
implemented at the government level in Bhutan.
And it's interesting how that is happening now.
And I wonder if,
because that intention was there that something like this is actually manifested
a very interesting relationship with intuition and manifestation,
but many different countries around the world from a government level or trying
to introduce this like in Goa,
uh,
with the installation they suggested 2019 what about if we had a festival on
zero waste?
Funny because the festival that we had this art installation for a year ago,
I suggested how about if we have our festival and zero waste festival and they
said,
well why don't you do it first and then we'll see how from the evaluation we
could do it.
And it's funny that the government is now suggesting completely unrelated,
but government is suggesting we have like a zero waste festival.
But I think they're all like pockets of people coming together and doing very
interesting things.
But for the,
for the world replenish index,
um,
at MIT last year in December I launched something called the replenish business
canvas.
And I wanted to suggest that if every single startup not,
you know,
sort my company,
come to the end of it,
and now I've got the money,
I'll put some money towards CSR,
right at the beginning when you're formulating your company,
you could say that this company is going to be a zero waste company and where am
I going to get my military materials from?
So at writer inception,
you could introduce this whole idea,
what kind of businesses would we have in the future?
And you know,
I'm surprised,
but even at Harvard and Mit,
both of their MBA programs as well as Oxford site business school,
do not have enough case studies of businesses that have done extremely well in
this field.
So that's one of the projects within the world replenish index to build on the
case studies of business model innovation of where businesses have done it.
I've made it,
so it's a lot of work and I need a lot of help.
Um,
maybe some of you will help me.
Yeah.
[inaudible].